sai da moda e com as para vocês
a base esteja com vocês
essa é a saudação do islã
meu nome lá existe na sociedade onde
nasceu em damasco capital da síria e
onde em janeiro
estudei na universidade de damasco
hoje estou fechado no brasil com minha
família minha língua mãe é a hora em
hora em um bom poder de franchi do
português
por isso peço desculpas sim alguns
momentos é difícil entender
ok o farol hoje eu vou falar sobre o que
mais me incomoda o próprio inseto exerce
sobre o irã por causa de grupos
terroristas que não tem nada que ver
como islã ashes da guerra
a síria era bonita e tranquila barata e
fácil de se viver
a abolição era de 20 3 milhões de
pessoas
eu tinha minha família amigos que eu
conhecia desde criança
três do jazz de roupa ou escritório de
engenharia dois apartamentos e um carro
em damasco e gostava de viajar e adorava
conhecer o mundo
fui para países como estados unidos
espanha e frança
até que um dia começou a guerra 15 de
março de 2011
entrará depois chegam a todas as outras
cidades do país
minha cidade damasco era é mais segura
da síria tinha entrei piche e 25 bombas
por dia
depois de cinco anos de guerra
homem o país está destruído pessoal a
quem conheço fora obrigadas a carregar o
cadaval de seus filhos encontraram suas
esposas feriados e mutiladas por uma
bomba
familiares sumirá é não votar em mim os
últimos anos na síria fora muito
difíceis e não sabia
sei é voltar pra casa quando saía para
trabalhar
segue a via a minha família de novo ou
não
hoje milhões de sírios medraram tudo
estão mortos ou sem fio já eram encontro
os países
eu e minha família estávamos muito
triste quando tivemos que deixar a síria
pois nossos parentes em nossa vida
ficaram para trás e you ainda não sei se
vou conseguir voltar algum dia a minha o
país
meu pai e meu irmão ainda moura melhor e
não sei se eu viro eles novamente para
proteger minha família fui para a bahia
onde depois de dez meses e sob que o
brasil tenha aberto as portas para os
cílios
então fui conversar na embaixada
brasileira e desejam que são paulo era
um a melhor cidade para ir no brasil
por quê
tinha mais oportunidades eo teve apenas
uma semana para deixar pra trás
quarenta anos da minha vida é começar de
novo no brasil e cheguei aqui entendi
dezembro 2013 com minha família
dois filhos oriá de 11 anos era 18 hoje
eu tenho uma filha brasileirinha há nove
meses no brasil em uma festa para
comemorar o aniversário dos meus filhos
e todos falharam muito bem a comida que
minha esposa fez falharam para eu
aproveitar quem ele a cozinha muito bem
e fazer comida para vender ou aí quem eu
criei a da gina no facebook e outra lá a
comida é síria onde isso agora tudo tem
caneta e papel
isso quebrou nem melhorou eu tava comigo
a síria
eu faço comida entregou até boulou sabe
nós estamos felizes no brasil
agradecemos a receber sal do povo
brasileiro
vocês abriram as portas quando o mundo
estava fechado
brannon é trash que por conta da guerra
é de ataques terroristas
muitas pessoas tinha uma idéia errada
sobre os cílios é sobre o islã
hoje de manhã aqui uma jornalista fábio
convidou eu depois que aconteceu na
frança agora eu não quero falar
ao conversar o contactam com uma pessoa
um ser humano
acham que eu estou a gostar de sangue
que está permitido matar em nome da
religião mas é exatamente o bozo
o ataque que aconteceu em paris foi um
creme não sobrar franceses mas também
para nos os cílios
o estado islâmico é uma organização
terrorista que está sujando a imagem do
islã é uma religião de base o ano por on
nosso livro sagrado desses que mata uma
pessoa sem que ela tinha matado outra
osm ado corrupção na terra e como se
matar se todos os homens e que lê da
vida será como desse a vida a todos os
homens alcorão surah turma da escola 32
esses motoristas não respeitam nem os
muçulmanos
eles matam muçulmano sunita como eu e
minha vida no brasil me mostrou que
podemos
viver em paz em são paulo nem nenhum
tipo de briga em 3 cyrus e brasileiros
mesmo com as diferenças de cultura e
religião
quando as pessoas viram uma mulher
usando a hijab aquele lenço que cobre o
cabelo igual minha esposa ea minha
esposa
fazem perguntas como por que você usa e
seleção com esse calor você usa esse
lixo em casa também
além de hijab hoje não tendo outras
regras
um é mulher não podem se tocar e abraçar
e beijar e sexo eu sou de bois do
casamento
algumas pessoas me dizer mas eu já vi
uns humanos que fazem tudo isso e beijam
e abraçam beijam som é o extremo tem
essas regras mas vai de cada pessoa
querer cumprir ou não a bíblia também
proíbe algumas coisas assim
da mesma forma tanques aos que não
obedecem tudo não estão também não é
permitido comer carne de curto e nem
bebidas alcoólicas quando fui doar
sangue no brasil o médico me perguntou
se eu bebi álcool ou se fez isso com
mais de uma parceira isso não acontecerá
comigo
cortei cortei
essas coisas são proibidas bilhões não
nossa religião e muito importante para
nos mas apesar de não conhecer a moeda
depois que a agência explica as pessoas
sempre entendem respeito o profeta
muhammad disse que devemos respeitar
a todas as religiões que todas as
pessoas têm o mesmo valor e devemos
tirar de idade com todos não importa se
nçao brancos negros windows 8 também diz
que devemos ajudar as pessoas que
precisam todo ano temos olhos é k é de
montamos 2.5 por cento de todo o nosso
dinheiro para as pessoas mais pobres no
imprensa
se os pobres são muçulmanos crystals
hoje 10 que o companheiro vocês aprender
mais sobre o islã
tenho certeza que irá gostar e entender
tem uma religião de paz
agora minha o sonho aqui no brasil e que
o mundo conheça melhor o islão para
acabar com o preconceito
assim nem os filhos e seus filhos
balbo de crescer juntos em base você dá
mole